detection the condom breaks if you don't
know this girl I wouldn't have sex with
a girl I don't know listening
when did I do that I didn't hear you say
no I never banged somebody dies Below My
Level that I didn't want to be with and
I was ashamed
when did I I have no point in this
podcast
he didn't say that
your you know other people I wish you
you had like contested that very loud
then okay I'll I'll tell you my
perspective I think that if you are
going to have sex with someone there is
always a possibility that a child will
be a result of that always a possibility
you can lower that probability to
0.0001 but if you're having sex with
someone especially on a regular
especially if you're not using
protection and contraception then there
there's a there's a possibility
one night stand before
[Laughter]
let me answer the question and let me
answer the question if that happened
I would you know we live in this weird
world where the man only gets so much
say in these things but I would strongly
I would be like yo I got this I got you
I've got you right if that is the
situation and that happens I will step
up I will take my responsibility
I'm stepping up to get the morning off
the pill but
but if you're man enough to do what you
did then you should be man enough to
take the responsibility
you know there was a chance
the woman take responsibility as well
100 absolutely it takes two detangle
again like we all know how this stuff
works like I said the truth is people
want to be a men and women want to be
able to go out have complete random sex
be as promiscuous as they want whatever
and not face any of the consequences
and by the way Society did not used to
be like this
exercise
people need to start talking to their
children from Young I mean my
grandchildren are on the five
and I will talk to them about sex
education down to them who can touch
where you know whatever's underneath
your swimming culture is your area not
even glamor wash it because I don't wash
them because I'd like to say not even
glamor you know they know how to wash
themselves properly on their own
age one age two three and five
and my brother's dad died when he was
three years old
and I stepped in to help my mom I was a
child myself
and the way I I raised helped my mum
raise my brother
he went on a date when he was I think 14
of a girl I didn't particularly like her
I thought she was a bit forward you know
and you can tell that she didn't come
from a good household you know you get
them girls that come in they're over
friendly they want to start helping
doing this and doing that and it was
kind of weird and then he was going to
take you on a date and I'd always put my
brother up to let him know
16 is the age when you start having sex
and I petrified him I terrorized him
because I told him if you have sex under
16 the police will come and arrest you
because it's against the law to this day
he still remembers of that and he still
tells me off that you had me terrified
and he said that I remember he went out
with this girl and I taught him about
going out on dates and he said oh she
want the kids good night and I thought
oh he came home and he was really upset
he was storming around I think he was
about 14 13 14. I said what's wrong
because she asked me for a kiss because
you know she's trying to stick her
tongue in my mouth he goes what kind of
rubbish is that he said I went on a date
with her because I told him about you
know being a gentleman and going on a
date and stuff and we train my brother
even his wife now
he's 40 and even his wife now when they
came when she came round after they've
been dating and engaged you know my mom
and I you met my mum Gracie's Pearl's
new granny and you said were you my mom
I mean she in her day she was hilarious
we used to go into the chemists and like
Pharmacy again big one they had condoms
on offer
you know he was over 16 and he said oh
they've gone buy one get one free my mom
would be shouting out these ones are
colored these ones have got knobs oh no
and my brother used to get really
embarrassed because we used to buy him
condoms there was always and people oh
you're encouraging him to have sex no
we're encouraging that if he's gonna
have sex
have it safely and he he ended up
dumping that girl because she wanted him
to have sex
and in the back of his mind he knew he
was going to get arrested and locked up
but he's happily married now he's
happily married now with two lovely
children and because of the way he was
raised good he was raised like that and
he we had he had a fantastic death his
late dad was absolutely fantastic
better than my dad and my mom and dad
were married seriously better than my
dad but it needs to start from Young
because these modern women are going out
and they when you see the children of
these modern women you can see where
they're coming from where they're going
to end up and it takes a village I don't
see any
grandmothers I don't see people coming
around for dinner
you know I mean the first time I met
Pearl I had to go into Pearl's Place I
took around some drinks and snacks and
she was like oh but to me that's you you
took that I'm coming around there to
spend time with you you know I've had
children's you know people bringing
their children into my back Garden I
teach them how to you know where
potatoes come from to dig potatoes you
know I'm teaching my nephew how to make
bacon where bacon comes from because
there's not part of a pig called bacon
you know and things like that so if
people are teaching their children from
Young
extremely young now because it seems
like the age of having sex I mean I told
my brother 16. you know he was born in
1982 I think I was the name a 1985. I
was telling him 16. but now I'm married
at people having sex when they're 12.
so and and even younger so you need to
teach the children from Young
and everybody needs to teach I could
walk into East ham and I can where I
used to live and I can see children
misbehaving and I will stop them till
them off
they won't say another word they won't
go until their mother even where I live
now I don't know who they are I live by
a school and if I see children playing
up you know especially if there's the
white children they're giving them up a
bit like hey you're making that night
you know and the parents you can tell
they're grateful you know thank you and
there's no Village anymore
there's no Village anymore and that's
why these children are being turned up
to be like
cross causing can I say one thing though
can I say one thing yet like what you're
saying like 100 yeah I'm with you but we
live in a different time why do people
keep on saying that about changing it
there's all these positive people in
here there's all these positive people
in here there's all these people
watching the podcast and you can't just
sit back and allow it to happen I don't
allow it to happen if I went into your
house and you had children there and
they were misbehaving I'm not going to
sit there and shut up I want to put them
straight so if you can't say that no
this is otherwise we might not what's
the point of having this podcast trying
to change it if it's never going to
change I know but we are not you can't
just say we it's different times now
thinking well nothing's going to change
the difference no but what I'm trying to
say is that it will change it doesn't
matter whether it's different times now
because everything needs to turn back to
traditional because that's what needed
so even though times have changed now I
still have modern people with their
children in my house they're quite
happily drop them over for a bit of
discipline because they listen to you
you know my house I mean I haven't got
no kids in my back Garden is full of
swings and slides and art stuff and
whatever and I have them all around so
I'm gonna make the change it's gonna
start with me it can start with you it
can start with everybody else there's no
point saying oh this is the way it is
it's lost it's not going to change that
was back in the day because I'm people
might say that I'm always being in the
world but not of it so a lot of things
that happen out there don't affect me
because I'm not actually of the world
I'm just I'm just in it so as far as I'm
concerned in my little world
I don't get affected by that all the
children that come into my little world
they will never get affected by that
because I'm going to give them the same
base the same Foundation that I had and
if people start stop thinking oh you
know this is going to be they want to
teach my son about um Guru nanak when he
was in Primary School
and I said no put him in a different
class let him do some maths in English
you know sex education I had to go and
find out what it was all about before
because I knew that if it was a sex
education now there's no way you're
teaching my son and I'd actually go into
the school and say I don't want him in
there put him in another class because
they knew me well in Brampton Manor
because I was always down there walking
down there sought out the teachers and
the Headmaster but no people need to get
involved because I'm tired of hearing to
say oh it's different now nothing's
going to change nothing's going to
change because people are just sitting
about saying it's different now or
having talked about it without doing
something about it what I said though I
didn't say any of that what did you say
yeah I said it's a different time now
that's what I said and then you went on
no but it's a different time it's a
different time so let me finish what I'm
saying yeah at the end of the day as I
said initially I agree with what you're
saying yeah why it's a different time he
said but yeah and you didn't let me
finish so can I let me say what I'm
saying yeah at the end of the day my
ideology to it is we need a different
strategy to this because the the older
people of your generation and or
whatever like my mom's generation or
whatever yeah their mindset is of of how
it was when they were younger or how it
applies now it's not necessarily the
same kind of ball game you have to
evolve you have to evolve with the times
like I'm saying like the kids like for
instance kids nowadays do not care about
who's older or who's younger I know when
I was young if if an older guy came to
me and said something I'll be shook you
know what I'm saying you think the kids
now are shook they are not scared bro
they're out of me I've never met I have
never ever you go you can go and bring
me the worst kid ever and I'm telling
you bring me the initial challenge if
you've got a child
bring me the worst child ever I will
have your child for a weekend bring me
your child I've got cameras in my house
you can see what I do and I will hand
your child over to you at the end of the
weekend a different child I will
guarantee you that because I've been
doing it for years because people drop
off their children to me regularly
Auntie yeah I hear your point I hear you
there's no contingency plan because us
and a new generation we're formulating
or farming kids in this new school of
error and I feel like I understand your
point we need to adopt and keep the
standard the same height because at the
moment we're conforming to society and
making it seem that what's [ __ ]
excuse my language it's okay yeah and
that's the problem you need that good
foundation right though mind you though
I again as many of you know I was just
banned on Tic Tac and we are demonetized
on a daily basis on this platform if you
want to help please consider sending a
super thanks below every donation helps
and it helps make what we do possible